الآن هذا هو المكان المثالي لتناول طعام الغداء،
هذا هو سمك القاروص، أنت لا
تفهم مدى حماستي
لأكل السمك أخيرًا على شاطئ في يوكاتان. هل
تعلم أنني مندهش لأنه لم يعد هناك
المزيد من المأكولات البحرية في  مطبخ يوكاتان
في الماضي لم يكن لدى الناس
القدرة على تبريد الطعام في
منازلهم، كانت جدتي تخبرني أنه
عندما كبرت اعتقد الناس أنهم
سوف يمرضون من أكل
الأسماك التي يتم صيدها في الصباح
ومع  الحرارة التي قد تفسد الطعام بسرعة
كبيرة السمك محشو
بالثوم وإكليل الجبل والزعتر
والبرتقال الحامض المفضل في يوكاتان وبالطبع
جرعة صحية من الملح عندما يكون لديك
مكونات، هذه البساطة الطازجة هي المفتاح الذي
تخصصت فيه مثل فتح
فن الطهو هنا خارج
أطباق يوكاتان التقليدية أشعر أنه يوجد
هنا في يوكاتان الكثير من
المكونات الرائعة لدرجة أنني أريد فقط أن أترك
المكونات تتحدث عن نفسها، سنضع عليها
بعض الزيت للبدء،
وسنقوم بتحضير الفرشاة التي ستستخدمها هذه الفرشاة
كن سلاحنا السري لوضع
كل هذه الأعشاب في طبقات، إنها
فكرة رائعة فرشاة الأعشاب
[موسيقى]
فرشاة مصنوعة من البقدونس وإكليل الجبل والزعتر
هي أيضًا طريقة رائعة لتطبيق هريس الثوم،
أوه، هذا رائع سأقوم بعمل بعض
المانجو أيضًا  ملح الشواء
هذه هي فكرتي عن Food Heaven Julia،
لدي هذه كوجبتي الأخيرة على الأرض،
سأحضر بعض الدقيق وأحضر
الصلصة
[موسيقى]
السمك على الشاطئ الآن أشعر وكأنني في
المكسيك، أضع  البصل أولاً الآن للمكون
النجمي، هذا هو فلور دي سال،
وهذا هو ما حصدناه،
ستضع القليل منه، فما
السر في كل هذا، هو تتبيل
جميع المكونات إلى الكمال بحيث
عندما تضيفها  فلور دي سال
لا يتجاوز موسمه، نعم، حسنًا،
هذا السمك مذهل،
التباين بين الملح المقرمش والسمك الحلو
الناعم رائع للغاية. أشعر
أن يوكاتان لديها أكبر قدر من
التقدير للأرض والمطر
والطبيعة  العناصر والفاكهة
التي تأتي من الشجرة، مثل
هذا شكرًا لـ La Tierra، لدينا
مكونات لذيذة ومع
المكونات اللذيذة يمكننا إعداد وصفات لذيذة
[موسيقى]
أجنبية